you got engaged recently congratulations
just so that's very exciting news what
here's the question did you make a big
thing out of popping the questions you
have a plan I'm always curious how
people approach this so I'm a very
impatient person I'm also bad at keeping
secrets
I can also be a little neurotic Costa
Rica last summer to do a movie and it
kept getting pushed until I had to go
back to flash and I was out of the thing
but I thought I was gonna do it there
and I never went so we were we worked
out on the beach I forgot the ring was
in my backpack we were sitting on the
beach afterwards I thought she saw it
wait a minute there's your backpack no
she was putting her phone away and the
only backpack we had with us can I'm an
idiot an absent-minded as well on top of
this other you know Chloe she's looking
through a backpack where you've hidden
her engagement ring yeah she could use
it and did she find it no I spotted the
most lame like oh right no yeah
with such impromptu proposal and random
moment that she thought I was joking act
right when I proposed that's no good no
it was obviously not a very good
proposal at first she laughed right and
then you said seriously I'd say yes she
did say yes well I'm glad she fired
that's great said yeah is this happening
sooner you don't know I have no I have
no idea you guys have no set no we do
all right let me take now if she hadn't
looked in your backpack would you have
asked her maybe not in that moment to be
honest yeah no he waited for a better
time you know or not what are you
talking about
guys the guys very shaky by the way he
runs yeah I think you guys are burying
the headline now because didn't you say
you guys were working out on the beach
yeah yeah Wow you have a different
relationship than my wife and I hey
honey let's go work out together on the
beach she's a physical therapist okay
that's good that's good she helps me a
lot she works with you that's very nice
that's sweet
you